il a 72 ans elle en a 31 ans quand ils
se marient pour le meilleur et pour le
pire
pendant vingt ans le meilleur rime avec
champagne caviar diamant aux coutures et
condos de luxe meilleur du pire semble
avoir sonné pour le vieux président au
pouvoir depuis 37 ans robert mugabe est
trahi par ses frères d'armes
who dat robert cabé
je devais les côtes mitterrand de la
guerre d'indépendance réclame sa
destitution
[Applaudissements]
une fin terrible pour un héros
historiques
nelson mandela le site est souvent en
exemple robert mugabe a été un des
premiers leaders africains à combattre
un gouvernement blanc ouvertement
raciste celui de la rhodésie du sud
l'ancien du zimbabwe everybody rich au
poids car robert mugabe accorde cette
entrevue à sibiti en 1962 l'intellectuel
marque six a déjà pris les armes il
devient chef de guérilla
il va lutter contre l'oppression jusqu'à
la libération de son peuple
en 79 le premier ministre du nouveau mba
bout et tend la main à ses anciens
tortionnaires et leurs réserves des
postes-clés pendant 15 ans mais gab et
développe le pays à la vitesse grand v
des écoles des hôpitaux des logements
des routes sont construits les noirs ont
désormais accès à l'éducation aux soins
de santé et il travaille en 2000 le
président tente de relancer sa
popularité en lançant une réforme
agraire
les blancs sont expulsés de leur ferme
au profit de proches du régime qui
souvent ne connaissent rien à
l'agriculture le président provoque
ainsi une crise économique qui perdure
encore aujourd'hui
depuis le début de son règne me gaver
écrase ses opposants il remporte les
élections en semant la terreur comme ici
en 2008
depuis les mba bout et se sont résignés
à attendre la mort du vieux lyon l'élu
gaby veut assurer sa pérennité en
poussant sa femme ou devant de la scène
[Applaudissements]
du jour au lendemain
chris mugabe plongeant politique grave
les rangs du parti remplit les stades il
y a dix jours elle dénoncé le vice
président depuis 1990 tels le
vice-président complotent un coup d'état
lendemain de ce discours le numéro deux
du gouvernement été limogé une semaine
plus tard le couple mugabe est détrônée